(audience clapping)
I didn't know
what had happened in the documentary,
I was shocked because I went through the exact same thing
and it made me feel so much closer to you.
I love that you are out there advocating,
channeling your inner Elle Woods in Washington;
tell me about that, I was so on that journey.
Thank you.
It was the most empowering and proudest moment of my life
to be on Capitol Hill and speaking about something
that caused me so much pain and trauma,
but the fact that I can really turn that pain into a purpose
and make such a difference and already have changed laws
in seven states, and now working with
Representative Khanna and Senator Merkley
on the Accountability for Congregate Care Act.
And next we are gonna be taking it to a federal level
to push it to all 50 states so the abuse that happened
to myself and so many others will be illegal today.
Seven states.
(audience clapping)
Yeah, seven states.
And I love the resilience too.
What is your advice to people
to making all of that your strengths?
I would say to anyone who's been through trauma,
just to speak about it and let it out
and I really believe the truth will set you free.
And just for me, this was something I had-
I feel like these places,
they really instill that in the children,
they want them to feel ashamed.
They want everyone to say to them,
"No one's ever gonna believe you,"
because they don't wanna be caught
for what they've done to these people.
So my advice is to share your truth, tell someone,
hold these people accountable and tell your story
and others are not gonna feel alone
and it's gonna help make a difference.
God, (clapping) you are going to help
so many people with this.
(audience clapping)
You are going to set them free,
you are going to empower them,
that will actually matriculate into them helping
other people; it has a domino effect.
Bravo on everything, truly.
Thank you.
(audience clapping)
Truly, truly, truly.
It's so amazing!
Okay, I just learned about your painting?
Yes.
Tell me everything.
Well, I've loved art my whole life.
My grandmother taught me how to paint
and just during quarantine was finally,
when I wasn't traveling, I wasn't running around everywhere;
I was at home and I made whole art room
and I was painting and doing a lot of things for charity.
And then now doing digital art,
and it's just been incredible.
We just started doing a new one right now,
which is going to be about this topic,
about turning your pain into purpose.
I love doing art, I love painting, I love drawing.
Just it's something that I really enjoy,
but I love digital art even more.
I've been learning how to make digital art
and there's a lot that goes into it and it's just,
I love how you can make it 3D and movement and use sound
and it's just the future of art; it's so much fun.
And the fact that anyone with the talent
can put their art online and, for the rest of time,
they will always get commission on every sale;
and in the traditional art world,
that was never possible before,
it would just be on the first sale
and then they'd never seen anything again.
And then you're a DJ,
Mm-hmm.
which I love so much,
'cause I'm such a music nut.
Yes.
And you give me hope for myself and anyone
that what I try to do with this show
or what I try to have as a north star in life,
is that we are all not one thing;
we are such multi-faceted creatures,
and you're that living example.
Thank you.
(audience clapping)
Love you.
(bright music)